There was a lot of improvisation,
Yeah.
In the booth, is that right Zach, Kumail?
You guys would improvise a little bit
sometimes in the booth and it would
get a little dirty, wouldn't it?
Well we're on a HBO show, so you
sort of get use to
improvising in that vein.
[Kumail] We're on a
HBO show where the most
famous bit is how quickly can you
jerk off all the guys in the room.
[Zach] So I would, we would forget,
or at least I would forget
it was a kids' movie.
I remember at one point (laughs)
improvising something where it's like,
well why don't you go home and
choke yourself with a belt
while you masturbate. (laughs)
(laughing)
And I was like, that can't be,
that can't be in this movie.
(laughing)
Now my guess is that there are,
at least four publicists backstage
for the LEGO Ninjago Movie.
(laughing) Oh do you think, (laughing),
uh this is my last time on
television. (crowd laughing)
It's a pleasure to meet you.
[Conan] It's fantastic,
and it, it would get dark.
You guys would go to dark places.
Yeah, I mean, you know, I don't think
it gets darker than, choke yourself
to death while you're
masturbating. (laughing)
It's tough to top that,
Yeah.
but you know.
Yeah, we would,
they were like the
director was so supportive.
Cause, right after Zach, did that,
they were like all right
let's take a moment.
That was really good. (laughing)
But there's no way that
they would let that,
cause we just, Charlie
the director was so great,
he came up with this
thing that he was like,
hopefully that the studio would
let us do it, and my character.
I play the mom, to Dave Franco and,
I'm trying to cheer him up so I made
his favorite dish, which were dumplings.
Uh huh.
And the whole bit
was just, if I could just say,
well just take a dump on your way to bed.
Or just take one of mom's dumps with you.
You love mom's dumps.
Come on they're dumps, like,
Yeah.
and we like
I already took
a few dumps at school, I'm not, I'm not
in the mood.
Oh come on,
but you love mom's dumps.
Come on, you love mom's dumps.
Put one of mom's dumps
right in your mouth.
You love em.
That seemed, we could pass that through,
they said no way to that.
So definitely, no way to dumps,
then no way to
whatever your thing was.
[Zach] Yeah, that's not
It shouldn't have.
So the stand,
(laughing) so the standards
for the movie are much higher
than what we're doing here now.
[Group] Yeah. (laughing)
Yeah.
Oh yeah, right when they said
that's not going to work I was like,
I'm going to say that on CONAN. (laughing)
(cheering)